monsieur le président élu cher emmanuel
macron je suis heureux de votre présence
ici pour cette cérémonie
vous avez voulu y participer
comme pour montrer la volonté de
poursuivre le devoir de mémoire et ainsi
de préparer l'avenir
je veux saluer le président du sénat qui
chaque année organise cette
commémoration avec le président ici du
comité je tiens aussi à remercier pour
leur présence le premier ministre le
président de l'assemblée nationale des
membres du gouvernement les
parlementaires du sénat et de
l'assemblée nationale et de nombreux au
printemps d'associations c'est cette
union la qui est essentiel dans ces
instants où il faut dépasser les
clivages et les sensibilités pour nous
hisser au niveau des exigences de la
république c'est la dernière fois que je
participe en tant que président à cette
cérémonie du jardin du luxembourg
la première je m'en souviens c'était en
mai 2012 et je faisais ici respecter une
tradition qui avait été voulue par
jacques chirac dont vous avez rappelé le
rôle pour la décision qu'il avait prise
de cette journée de commémoration mais
on se dit mais 2017
notre rassemblement prend un caractère
symbolique le 10 mai c'est une date qui
compte dans l'histoire de notre pays
le 10 mai c'est la volonté qui avait été
celle de ceux qui avaient instauré cette
journée c'est la commémoration de
l'esclavagé des traites
et de l'abolition mais se trouve que le
10 mai 2010cette vient après une
élection présidentielle ou dimanche
dernier les françaises et les français
ont affirmé leur attachement à la
république marqué leur adhésion à des
valeurs fondamentales à ses principes
qui nous unissent tous et qui s'appelle
tolérance respect dignité démocratie
ouverture alors je voulais en cette
journée non pas simplement rappeler
l'histoire elle est connue mais dire que
longtemps elle a été enfoui occulté avec
sans doute cette tentation de l'effacer
il a fallu du temps et beaucoup de
combat pour faire en sorte qu enfin
cette mémoire puissent être pleinement
reconnu par la république
il ya d'abord eu la loi du 30 juin 2000
1983 qui a institué jours fériés la date
de proclamation de l'abolition de 1848
dans chaque département d'outre-mer car
les populations de guadeloupe de guyane
de martinique de la réunion de mayotte
elle n'avait jamais oublié ce moment
plein d'émotion et de ferveur où leurs
ancêtres étaient devenus immédiatement
des citoyens et des citoyennes français
comme cela nous a été rappelé tout à
l'heure lors de l'exposition en évoquant
cette loi aujourd'hui 1983 j'ai une
pensée pour henri emmanuelli disparu
cette année car il était le secrétaire
d'état chargé des départements et
territoires d'outre-mer et il avait
défendu ce projet devant le sénat
et devant l'assemblée nationale en 1988
la république à célébrer le 150e
anniversaire de l'abolition
par la voix de lionel jospin à champagné
champagney ce village de haute saône où
je suis allé récemment et dont les
habitants avaient demandé en 1789 dans
les cahiers de doléances l'abolition de
l'esclavagé
c'est aussi à ce moment que la société a
fait réapparaître le souvenir du crime
et des souffrances qu'il avait provoqué
le 13 mars 1998
les écrivains edouard glissant et
patrick chamoiseau et le prix nobel vol
soyinka lens à la sorbonne une
déclaration nommant la traite négrière
et l'esclavagé perpétrés dans les
amériques l'océan indien crime contre
l'humanité alors le 23 mai 1998
des milliers des dizaines de milliers
même de descendants d'esclaves
manifestèrent à paris pour revendiquer
cette reconnaissance ce mouvement s'est
poursuivi
il a été consacré par la loi du 21 mai
2001 la loi tout bien la république a
alors solennellement reconnu l'esclavagé
et la traite
je salue christiane taubira à cet
instant
vous l'aviez fait sans l'avoir car sa
voix peut porter même quand elle ne dit
rien la république avait reconnu
l'esclavagé la traite comme un crime
contre l'humanité mais il y en a
toujours qui s'en étonne et pourtant ce
sont les historiens qui leur répondent
il leur rappelle que de 1794
le législateur qualifié l'esclavagé de
crime de lèse humanité comme s'il y
avait déjà cette préfiguration de ce que
fut pourtant ce crime et sa
reconnaissance bien un crime jugé
alors si grave
à cette époque que le coupable était
automatiquement privé de sa citoyenneté
et même de sa nationalité
selon les lois adoptées par la
république après l'abolition de 1848
on était sévère à cette époque ces lois
ont été en vigueur pendant cent ans les
archives montrent que les sanctions ont
été effectivement appliqué chaque fois
que l'on remettait en cause le crime de
lèse majesté de lèse humanité
il vous est même arrivé que la majesté
puisse être lui-même un criminel de lèse
humanité la loi de 2001 n'est donc pas
une rupture mais à rappel elle ne dicte
pas l'histoire elle la transmet et c'est
le sens des institutions qu'elle a créée
je pense notamment au comité national
pour la mémoire et l'histoire de
l'esclavagé
présidée aujourd'hui par frédéric régent
a pas après l'avoir été par maryse condé
françoise vergès et myriam cottias il a
fallu aussi améliorer la connaissance et
la diffuser et c'est non seulement la
belle initiative qui a été prise en 2015
avec le ministère de l'éducation
nationale le concours de la flamme de
l'égalité et nous venons d'en remettre
les prix je pense enfin à la journée du
10 mai que jacques chirac a été le
premier à présider et qui est maintenant
ancrée dans le calendrier républicain et
puis il y à cette loi sur l'égalité
réelle
outre mer que nous avons voulu que la
ministre a porté et qui aujourd'hui
également est une loi qui est devenu une
grande loi républicaine en 2006 dans le
discours que ici même jacques chirac
avait prononcé il avait affirmé que pour
que cet événement vivent dans la durée
il fallait l'incarner dans un lieu de
mémoire de travail et des changes
il avait alors confié à edouard glissant
la mission d'imaginer ce lieu il avait
fait des propositions edouard glissant
qui était resté hélas lettre morte
alors je n'ai pas voulu qu'elle reste
plus longtemps oubliée j'ai d'abord
apporter le soutien de l'état à la
création du mémorial acte
cette grande réalisation voulu et porté
par victorin lurel et la région
ouaddou gelé moi même inauguré le 10 mai
en présence de nombreux chefs d'état du
gouvernement des gouvernements de
l'afrique et de la caraïbe
avant de me rendre à haïti parce que je
tenais aussi à parler de l' esclavage à
haïti et de la responsabilité qui avait
été celle de la france sur la terre même
où les esclaves ont peiné le mémorial à
act offre désormais à tous les visiteurs
un parcours qui rappelle ce que fut ce
système odieux qui permit à des êtres
humains d'en posséder d'eau de les
acheter de les revendre comme des biens
meubles et de les exploiter comme des
bêtes de somme mais le parcours du
mémorial acte montre aussi que de ce
crime atroce est sorti une population
mélangée à émerger une nouvelle
civilisation de nouvelles manières de
résister de s'affirmer qui ont engendré
de nouvelles formes d'art de culture
riche et métissée du racisme le plus
abject est ainsi née une forme
d'universel ce phénomène que le poète
appelle la créolisation du monde
il restait à donner à cette mémoire
l'institution nationale qui lui manquait
c'est pourquoi j'avais annoncé l'année
dernière que je souhaitais que la france
puisse se doter d'une fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavagé des traites et de
leurs abolitions lyonnaise ou à dessiner
les concours dans un rapport qu'il m'a
remis aux le 8 mars dernier ainsi qu'au
premier ministre le 3 mai 2017
j'ai présidé à l'elysée la cérémonie de
signature des statuts du groupement
d'intérêt public qui va donc préfigurer
la fondation son siège sera à l'hôtel de
la marine
là où même victor schoelcher a signé le
décret d'abolition de l'esclavagé
il y à 162 non il y à un chèque chez
chaque président élu
beaucoup d'émotion et d'image de
sentiments qui surgissent quelles
promesses réaliser quels engagements
respectés et sur lesquelles il faudra
veiller et puis il y a aussi des rêves
que l'on peut porter et qui n'ont pas de
caractère financier qui n'ont pas
forcément été au coeur d'une campagne
électorale
il ya aussi ses gestes et ses actes
mémorial qu'il nous faut accomplir et en
je me souvenais des paroles d'edouard
glissant de ceux qui m'avaient été
transmis pour qu'un jour il y ait une
fondation pour la mémoire de l'esclavagé
des traites et de leurs abolitions
et permettez moi de dire que je suis
fier que pour une des dernières
cérémonies sans doute la dernière avant
que je ne remette la totalité de mes
pouvoirs n'ayez aucune crainte
je la garderais au cas d'autres à
emmanuel macron président est venu donc
mes responsabilités que cette dernière
cérémonie soit pour consacrer une
promesse que j'avais faite à tous ceux
qui voulaient cette fondation
eh bien oui aujourd'hui je suis fier
qu'il puisse y avoir cette fondation
elle sera présidée par jean marc ayrault
et je le remercie d'avoir accepté cette
mission et à côté des représentants de
l'état les institutions financières ici
présente des associations des fondations
cinq personnes qualifiées porteront avec
lui cette ambition doudou diène ancien
responsable du programme la route de
l'esclave olivier laouchez est président
d'un groupe de médias les lacie
réalisatrice françoise vergès et lionel
gazeau que je remercie encore pour avoir
préparé cette mission est bien le rôle
de cette fondation sera de travailler
avec toutes les organisations tous les
acteurs qui ont à coeur d'assurer la
mémoire de l'esclavagé d'être apte et
qui seront associés d'une façon ou d'une
autre à son conseil d'orientation la
fondation travaillera avec la ville de
paris à la réalisation d'un monument et
d'un lieu muséal dédié à cette mémoire
et puis en 2018
la fondation sera officiellement bâti et
leur a vocation à être un pont entre
l'europe l'amérique l'afrique et l'océan
indien
c'est toujours le rôle de la france de
lancer des passerelles de faire que des
civilisations se rend compte que les
dires les cultures puissent dialoguer
c'est toujours le rôle de la france
d'être en avant-garde
c'est elle qui avait aboli la première
laisse cavage mais il faut toujours
avoir un esprit de résistance et de
vigilance
la même france qui peut être glorieuse
peut parfois retombé dans ses errements
il ya toujours des tentations il ya
toujours des forces plus ou moins
obscurs qui essayent de tirer la france
là où elle ne veut pas aller mais où
elle est parfois apeurés et chercheurs
un autre destin que celui que la
république lui a fixé alors c'est cette
france
c'est cette grande france que nous
devons que vous devez continuer à
réconcilier rassembler à réunir pour
qu'elle soit toujours sur la bonne
direction
jamais nous devons restaurer le monde
d'avant les esclavages d'avant la traite
c'est aimé césaire qui le disaient en
disant que ce qui s'était passé était
irréparable
on n'efface pas le passé on le dépasse
il faut alors posé des actes d'abord
l'acte de dire de déclarer de parler
face aux mémoires blessées
c'est la vérité qui libère et c'est
l'oubli qui exclut c'est la lucidité qui
grandit et c'est le déni qui divise
voilà pourquoi il faut aller jusqu'au
bout de la reconnaissance c'est ce
qu'avait fait jacques chirac au vel
d'hiv en 1995 c'est ce que nicolas
sarkozy a fait à constantine en 2007 ce
que j'ai fait à mon tour au vel d'hiv à
drancy
c'est ce que j'ai fait ensuite à tiarei
au sénégal en souvenir des tirailleurs
sénégalais a sacré en 1944
qu'est ce que j'ai fait a pas fait quand
j'ai reconnu les conséquences des essais
nucléaires français
c'est ce que j'ai fait à montreuil
bellay à propos des gens du voyage
interné par la france entre 1940 et 1946
et qu'il avait toujours pas le droit
d'être citoyen inscrit qu'il devait
avoir un carnet pour se déplacer c'est
ce que j'ai fait à madagascar
près de soixante dix ans après leers la
répression de l'insurrection
sur la grande île c'est ce que je fais
le 19 mars pour la guerre d'algérie
c'est ce que j'ai fait aussi pour la
reconnaissance de la responsabilité de
la france lors de la journée nationale
des harkis qui ont été abandonnés il
s'agit pas d'opposer une douleur à une
autre la concurrence des mémoires est un
mensonge
il n'y a pas de reine de hiérarchie dans
l'horreur de la souffrance dans la
barbarie
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire des
comparaisons nous sommes là pour
empêcher que ce qui a été le pire puisse
se reproduire poser des actes c'est
aussi donner à la mémoire institutions
des lieux des symboles comme cette
journée qui nous rappel aux devoirs
contre toutes les idéologies qui avant
des hiérarchies entre les peuples entre
les gens entre les races même si ce mot
ne devrait plus figurer dans la
constitution
oui nous devons continuer à nous battre
contre l'indifférence et le pire des
maux indifférence à la souffrance
indifférence à la guerre
indifférence aux massacres indifférence
face aux dictatures
alors qu'aujourd'hui dans le monde des
enfants des femmes des hommes sont
privés de liberté prostituées livré aux
phrases au trafic à l'exploitation sur
tous les continents
vous voulez de rappeler monsieur le
président du sénat ce qui avait fait
beaucoup haram en enlevant des jeunes
filles que l'on a retrouvé pas tout
et la plupart meurtri et qui doivent pas
être discriminée à cause de ce qu'elles
ont subi
les femmes qui subissent des violences
ne pas être regardé parce qu'elles ont
subi
des violences mais parce qu'elles ont
droit à la dignité et à l'égalité au
respect oui nous devons continuer à nous
battre contre les divisions qui
déchirent les peuples y compris ici
contre les discours qui jette les gens
les uns contre les autres
contre les as les intégristes contre les
obscurantistes contre les
communautarismes
il ya encore beaucoup à faire monsieur
le président cette journée nationale
nous rappelle que la france n'est
vraiment la france que lorsqu'elles
portent la voix de la liberté celle des
hommes dont les noms sont gravés sur les
murs du panthéon louis delgrès ce
toussaint louverture victor schoelcher
aimé césaire et celle des femmes dont
l'histoire n'a pas retenu les noms et
qui ont été aussi résistantes avec
courage contre l'abjection d'un système
qui leur dénier toute l'humanité vivent
ces femmes anonymes qui ont fait là
d'imiter de l'apprendre blain messieurs
depuis plusieurs semaines beaucoup de
pays la plupart d'ailleurs avaient les
yeux tournés vers la france à l'occasion
de l'élection présidentielle car ce qui
se passe en france a toujours une
résonance particulière dans le monde
parce que la france incarne un idéal un
mode de vie une culture parce qu'elle
porte un message qui n'est pas différent
des autres mais qui a été portée
peut-être plutôt qu'ailleurs et avec des
mots que nous avons inventé les droits
de l'homme l'égalité
nous sommes la première nation à avoir
aboli l esclavage et aussi avoir conquis
des droits et des libertés
voilà pourquoi il est plus que jamais
nécessaire de faire la paix des mémoires
comme l'écrivait glissant nous entrerons
alors il parlait il ya presque vingt ans
nous entraînons nous entrerons alors
dans l'archipel
inédit
où les communautés humaines pourront se
connaître ce équivaloir échangés en
échangeant sans pour autant se perdre ni
se dénaturer voilà le message du 10 mai
c'est la journée de la mémoire de l
esclavage des traîtres et des abolitions
mais c'est surtout le projet de la
république et c'est toujours et ce sera
toujours le message de la france
il vous revient maintenant monsieur le
président chers emmanuel de porter ce
message de le porter ici en france de le
porter en europe et partout dans le
monde
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]